>>> QUEEN ELIZABETH II SPENT HER
FINAL DAYS AT HER HOME AWAY FROM
HOME, BALMORAL CASTLE, WHICH HAS
BEEN A SANCTUARY SINCE THE DAYS
OF QUEEN VICK TORE.
PRINCE ALBERT BOUGHT IT FOR
QUEEN VICTORIA.
MEMBERS OF THE ROYAL FAMILY SAY
IT WAS A HAPPY REFUGE FOR QUEEN
ELIZABETH, WHEN SHE COULD GET
AWAY FROM THE RIGORS OF REGULAR
LIFE, WHERE SHE COULD HUNT
GROUSE, FISH.
IT'S ALSO WHERE SHE SPENT MUCH
OF HER HUSBAND, PRINCE PHILIP'S
REMAINING YEARS WITH HIM.
>> I THINK GRANNY IS MOST HAPPY
THERE.
I THINK SHE REALLY, REALLY LOVES
THE HIGHLANDS.
>> Reporter: BALMORAL CASTLE,
LOCATED ON 50,000 ACRES IN THE
SCOTTISH HIGH LANDS.
IT WAS THE PREFERRED SUMMER
RETREAT OF QUEEN ELIZABETH.
>> PICNICS, DOGS.
A LOT OF DOGS.
ALWAYS DOGS.
AND PEOPLE COMING IN AND OUT ALL
THE TIME.
>> Reporter: FREE FROM PUBLIC
DUTY, THE QUEEN COULD RELAX AND
SPEND TIME LOVING HER BELOVED
HORSES, HIKING, AND PLAYING
GAMES LIKE CHARADES WITH FAMILY
MEMBERS.
>> IT'S A LOVE BASE FOR GRANNY
AND GRANDPA TO BE FOR US TO COME
SEE THEM, UP WHERE YOU HAVE ROOM
TO BREATHE AND RUN.
>> Reporter: FOR ALL THE
SPLENDOR, BALMORAL WAS KNOWN AS
HOMEY, RUSTIC.
THERE WAS EVEN A CUSHION
EMBROIDERED WITH THE WORDS "IT'S
GOOD TO BE QUEEN."
FORMER PRIME MINISTER TONY BLAIR
HAS DESCRIBED A WEEKEND AT
BALMORAL AS A COMBINATION OF
INTRIGUING, SURREAL, AND UTTERLY
FREAKY.
WHERE PRE-DINNER DRINKS WERE,
QUOTE, TRUE ROCKET FUEL, AND THE
QUEEN HERSELF WOULD DO THE
WASHING UP.
THEY PUT THE GLOVES ON AND STICK
THEIR HANDS IN THE SINK.
THE QUEEN ASKS IF YOU FINISHED.
SHE STACKS THE PLATES UP, AND
GOES OFF TO THE SINK.
FOR BRITAIN'S LONGEST-SERVING
MONARCH, BALMORAL HELD A
SENTIMENTAL SIGNIFICANCE.
>> IT'S MY FOOT YOU'RE STANDING
ON.
>> Reporter: IT WAS WHERE YOUNG
ELIZABETH MET A THEN OFFICER IN
THE BRITISH ARMY, WHO WOULD
LATER BECOME HER HUSBAND, PRINCE
PHILIP.
IT WAS ALSO AT BALMORAL THAT THE
ROYAL FAMILY, INCLUDING PRINCE
HARRY AND PRINCE WILLIAM,
LEARNED OF THE DEATH OF THEIR
MOTHER, PRINCESS DIANA.
IN HAPPIER TIMES, THE BALL WAS
AT BALMORAL, A SCOTTISH DANCE
PARTY FROM THE TIME OF QUEEN
VICTORIA, HELD TO THANK THE
ROYAL STAFF FOR THEIR HARD WORK.
BUT IT WAS THE LANDSCAPE THAT
HELD THE MOST APPEAL FOR THE
QUEEN.
THE WALKS ALONG THE HILL
SURROUNDING THE PROPERTY, THE
HUNTS, THE PICNICS, AND OF
COURSE HER DRIVES AROUND THE
ESTATE IN HER LAND ROVER.
A BELOVED PLACE OF HISTORY AND
OF SYMBOLISM, A FITTING END TO
HER MAJESTY'S FINAL DAYS, AT
HOME AT BALMORAL.
>> ISA SOARES JOINS US NOW FROM
INVERIENS IN SCOTLAND.
CAN YOU DESCRIBE THE QUEEN'S
RELATIONSHIP WITH THE ROYAL
STAFF AT BALMORAL?
I UNDERSTAND THEY WERE QUITE
CLOSE.
>> Reporter: THEY WERE VERY
AS YOU HEARD IN THAT PIECE
THERE, IT REALLY OUTLINED WHAT
BALMORAL MEANT REALLY TO HER
FROM SUCH A YOUNG AGE.
AND THAT OF COURSE NOT JUST AS A
YOUNG DAUGHTER THERE BUT
OBVIOUSLY BECOMING A FIANCE,
THEN BECOMING A WIFE, MOTHER,
AND A GRANDMOTHER.
SO, THE MEMORIES SHE HOLDS THERE
ARE SO CLOSE TO HER HEART.
LIKE MANY OF US, IT'S HOME IN
MANY WAYS.
THIS IS WHERE SHE SPENT MUCH OF
HER RESIDENCE.
AND OF COURSE THE STAFF ARE VERY
PART OF REALLY THE FURNITURE IN
MANY WAYS.
SHE GOT TO KNOW THEM FROM A VERY
YOUNG AGE.
I THINK TODAY THAT'S WHY YOU
REALLY FEEL LIKE THE SADDEST OF
EVENINGS HERE, ANDERSON.
I THINK THERE'S A COLLECTIVE
SENSE OF SHOCK AND GRIEF BUT
ALSO OF ADMIRATION FOR THIS
INCREDIBLE MONARCH AND
MATRIARCH.
AND I THINK IT DOESN'T MATTER IF
YOU'RE IN LONDON, ANDERSON, OR
IF YOU'RE IN SCOTLAND, THE
COMMENTS I'VE BEEN HEARING FROM
VERY MUCH THE SAME.
ONE PERSON SAID TO ME TODAY, I
CAN'T QUITE UNDERSTAND WHY I
FEEL LIKE I'M GRIEVING, THOUGH
I'D NEVER MET THE QUEEN.
AND IT'S BECAUSE FOR ABOUT 80%
OF THE POPULATION HERE, THERE'S
ONLY BEEN ONE MONARCH, AND THAT
IS THE QUEEN.
AND THAT'S WHY WE'VE SEEN SCENES
OUTSIDE BALMORAL CASTLE OF
PEOPLE BOWING THEIR HEADS,
LAYING DOWN FLOWERS, PAYING
TRIBUTE TO A WOMAN REALLY THAT
HAS DEFINED THEIR LIFE, BEEN
THEIR CONSTANT THROUGHOUT.
AS ONE OF THE QUEEN'S FORMER
PRIVATE SECRETARIES SAYS, THE
QUEEN WAS A CONSTANT LIGHT AND
NORTHERN STAR.
THAT'S HOW CONSTANT SHE WA